dream
scenario is a
masterpiece this movie is about an
average professor and then overnight bam
people around the world start dreaming
about him he just sort of walking
through these dreams and doing nothing
and that also is frustrating to him cut
I wouldn't have dreamt of having
Nicholas Cage once he was on board the
movie took on this meta layer of having
a impossibly famous person playing an
unremarkable every
man this is a brand new experience for
me as an
actor it's exciting the playoff of an
actor that I admire so much Brian right
Paul I had the life experience to play
him authentically because what happened
to so-called Nick Cage with the
internet why me uh I don't know I'm
special I
guess